[Music]
champagne toasts are common at weddings
birthdays and many other special
occasions but if the cork isn't secured
properly
it can pop off at the wrong moment so
champagne manufacturers have developed
hoods and foils
to keep the bottles closed until the
right moment
the foil covering that protects the cork
is part of the iconic champagne look
unwrapping it is like opening a special
present
underneath the foil is a wire hood and
disc that keeps everything in place
the flat discs begin as thin sheets of
steel
a suctioning device transfers the sheets
to a printing machine
[Music]
the machine slices the sheets into
strips
then the suctioning device moves the
strips to the next step in the
production line
it positions the strips on a machine
that quickly punches out the round disc
components
the wire hoods are made out of
galvanized steel
a series of large bobbins feed the steel
into a multi-phase machine
the wire is coated with colored lacquer
for increased protection
and aesthetic appeal
[Music]
on a rotating carousel the machine
twists two horizontal strands of wire
it leaves enough room for a vertical
loop between each set of twists
next the device twists the vertical loop
a blade cuts the wire in between each
newly formed cross
[Music]
then a mechanism removes the crosses and
transfers them to the next stage of
production
a machine shapes the bottom of the
crosses in three steps
first it pinches the wire together at
the four extremities
then it forms a bend and finally it
folds them over to create a hook
[Music]
a device folds the feet up and hooks
them onto a wire circle called a belt
the wire structures are ready for the
disc insert
a press forces the discs into a die to
create rounded caps
finally the machine inserts the newly
formed caps into the wire structure
[Music]
the champagne wire hoods are now
complete and ready for their bottles
it takes 15 steps to build a wire hood
incredibly the machine can build each
hood in under two
seconds
the wire hood holds the cork in place
but the poly laminate foil wrapper
protects it from the elements
this specially made foil is composed of
polythene film
sandwiched between two sheets of
aluminum
[Music]
a high speed cutter trims the edges then
the poly laminate rolls through a bath
of varnish
[Music]
the polythene film is made out of
granules
[Music]
they dye the poly laminate gold using a
high speed printing process
[Music]
the poly laminate foil is coated with
specially formulated ink
that dries instantly under ultraviolet
light
[Music]
the foil transfers to a perforation
machine
this allows customers to easily unwrap
the champagne bottle
a hot stamping machine adds decorative
elements
and the brand name to the foil
another device adds a strip of glue to
one edge
a machine cuts the foil then a device
equipped with cylindrical rods called
mandrels
wraps the foil into cones
[Music]
the glue strip holds the cone together
a machine places a disc on top of the
cones
they crimp the ends to increase the
cone's rigidity
then a vacuum sucks the completed cones
off the mandrels
no bottle of bubbly is complete without
a hood and foil
this factory quickly produces both in
any style or color the winery requests
[Music]
the factory speed and versatility allows
them to produce wire hoods and foils
for 50 of the sparkling wines made in
[Music]
france
you